encore une nouvelle collection bon
marché dans un domaine qui en france est
décidément toujours très inventif celle
ci s'appelle assez drôlement les
classiques modernes et elle est publiée
par le livre de poche c'est une sorte de
pléiade de poche précisément vendu 140
francs pour mille trois cent cinquante
pages de texte la présentation est très
soigné le papier très blanc et le choix
des caractères très harmonieux le
premier volume de la collection
rassemble les romans le théâtre les
poèmes et les textes sur le jazz de
boris vian à deux ans près boris vian
est l exact contemporain gérard philipe
il était comme eu un grand malade et
tous deux continuent d'incarner
durablement une certaine image de la
jeunesse né en 1920 vian est au fond un
concentré de son époque celle de la
guerre et de la libération il était
ingénieur diplômé de l'école centrale
mais aussi trompettiste de jazz
traducteur de romans policiers
américains et notamment de raymond de
chant de l'air pour la célèbre série
noire il était aussi collaborateur des
temps modernes de jean paul sartre et
simone de beauvoir ainsi que de jazz hot
auteur de chansons célèbres comme le
déserteur c'était également l'ami
d'albert camus de jean genet de jacques
prévert et de raymond queneau
1965 boris vian est mort depuis six ans
quelque peu oublié on réédite son
meilleur roman légumes des jours succès
stupéfiant qui ne s'est jamais démenti
depuis le livre est une sorte d'objet
culte pour les jeunes générations ont
inscrit au programme des grands concours
l'invention verbale conjuguée à la
poésie de l'enfance fond de son auteur
sinon un grand écrivain en tout cas
certainement un vrai romantique